aquí tenemos tres definiciones de
funciones hdx igual a 3x grt igual a
menos 2 t - 2 - hdt fn igual a menos 5
en el cuadrado más h de m como vemos son
tres funciones y de hecho dos de ellas
están en términos de otra función
nos preguntan el valor de hd g de 8 esto
puede parecer bastante confuso pero solo
debemos recordar que una función es algo
que toma una entrada y nos genera una
salida y este enunciado que parece algo
complejo es otra forma de decir que
debemos tomar el número 8 el número 8 y
ponerlo como entrada de la función g de
mi función g
y esta me va a generar una salida que es
g de 8 todavía no sé qué valor vaya a
ser de 8 y lo que sea que salga como
valor a su vez lo voy a tomar como
entrada para mi función h de aquí
que me va a generar la salida h d
de 8 hagamos una cosa a la vez veamos
cuánto es de 8 g
de 8 veamos la definición de la función
g
la entrada es 8 así que cada que veamos
aquí una t la vamos a sustituir por un 8
bueno vamos a hacer lo que de 8 va a ser
igual a menos 2
8 aquí es hay una tela sustituye por un
8 menos 2 por 8 - 2 - h y aquí hay una t
así que voy a poner un 8 h de 8 vamos a
calcular esta parte 8 x 12 16 con el
signo negativo es menos 16 menos 2 va a
ser igual a menos 18 menos h de 8 y
cuánto vale h de 8 bueno lo que tenemos
que hacer es tomar este hecho como
entrada y sustituirlo en nuestra función
h en donde veamos una x lo sustituimos
por un 8 así que está h de 8
es igual a 3 por 8 que es igual a 24 así
que todo esto es 24 con un signo
negativo es menos 24
que a su vez todo esto va a ser igual a
menos 18 menos 24 es igual a menos 42
ahora ya que tenemos este menos 42 que
es nuestra g de 8 vamos a ponerla como
entrada en la función h
ahora tenemos h
y menos 42 menos 42 que recordamos es lo
que nos sale como g de 8 va a ser igual
a 3 por lo que tenemos como entrada 3 x
menos 42 y esto es igual a menos 126
y así algo que lucía muy complicado al
principio resultó que no era tan difícil
de resolver simplemente no debemos
perder de vista cuáles son las entradas
y cuáles son las salidas de manera que
podemos evaluar estas funciones de una
forma bastante directa